il est dans un soutien permanent au
gouvernement ce qui est voulu demander
la riviera this you nabeul moi je lui
dis simplement cantonné dans un soutien
permanent au gouvernement eh bien il
faut en tirer naturellement les
conséquences on veut en dehors et donc
itélé l'air est dedans mais ça c'est à
lui de d'avoir cette attitude moi ce que
je regrette est ce que ce que ce que lui
disent les militants parce que c'est pas
nouveau
ils lui disent clarifier clarifie votre
août à fusil sur vous vous qui le
président de la commission d'investiture
de l air est ce que christian estrosi
pourra pourraient être investis libéré
public un tour la municipale à nice dans
deux ans nous verrons bien mais
aujourd'hui ce serait plutôt non je
dirais que c'est à lui de clarifier
c'est à lui de clarifier sa position